hi i'm chris potts i'm a professor in
linguistics at stanford with a courtesy
appointment in computer science and i'm
the director of stanford center for the
study of language and information which
is an interdisciplinary research center
focused on logic language decision
making human sentence processing and
computation
my undergraduate and graduate degrees
are all in linguistics the work i did
for my phd focused on topics in
linguistic pragmatics which is the study
of how language use is shaped by the
physical and social context that we're
in
at a certain point i went looking for
new ways to support those theories
quantitatively and that began my journey
into the world of natural language
processing i now think of myself as
being on a mission to help with the
sharing of ideas back and forth between
linguistics and nlp i've taught natural
language understanding nine times at
stanford with my first year in 2012. in
2012 we were just beginning to see how
nlu was going to revolutionize the field
and reshape the technology landscape
ibm's watson had recently won jeopardy
apple siri was new and the other tech
giants were on the verge of launching
their own intelligent assistance so
there was a widespread perception that
nlu was poised to have a transformative
impact on the world and that perception
was certainly correct since then nlu has
only become more central to the field of
nlp and to all of artificial
intelligence more generally and the
progress in the field has been amazing
we have more large nou data sets than
ever before and the level of innovation
in modeling and model analysis is just
astounding
as a result we can tackle more ambitious
problems than ever and there are
opportunities to find lots of creative
new ways to apply nlu to technology
development and scientific inquiry
so it's certainly an exciting moment to
welcome you to this course it's an
adapted version of the course we teach
on campus the course begins by covering
a wide range of models for distributed
word representations from there we
branch out into a series of important
nlu topics including relation extraction
natural language inference and grounded
language understanding we've chosen
these topics because they allow us to
highlight many of the central concepts
in nlu which you can then apply more
widely
one of the special aspects of this
course is that it's project oriented and
with luck the project that you develop
will become a professional asset for you
we aim to help you design and conduct a
successful research project in the field
and we have an accomplished teaching
team to help you with this process
even the regular assignments are
oriented toward building original
projects each assignment is grounded in
a specific topic area and they all have
a common rhythm in that they ask you to
build up some baseline systems and then
develop your own original system for
solving the task at hand
you'll enter each one of these systems
into what we call a bake off which is an
informal competition around data and
modeling and the teaching team will
reflect the insights we gain from these
bake off entries back to the whole class
it's also common for bake off entries to
grow into final projects we hope that
all this work spurs you to think
creatively and to hone your practical
and theoretical skills in nlu so without
further ado let's get started